dans une saison le premier match à
domicile est souvent capital pour la
confiance face à Mulous leur bête noir
depuis 3 saisons les joueus du CTT des
lancour n'ont pas loupé leur rendez-vous
penelops ici en bleu n'a rien pu faire
face à la Roumaine Andrea mamaliga
malgré un bon niveau de jeu dans le
premier
match Yang a comme à son habitude
étouffé ses adversaires en ces deux
matchs 37 à1 avec beaucoup de
[Applaudissements]
sérénité dans un dernier match décisif
pour le moins tendu la nouvelle recrue
grecque Maria christophoraki l'emporte
1513 dans l'ultime manche après avoir
sauvé deux balles de
match
les joueux enctois sont désormais seuls
en tête de probé avec 6 points mais la
saison promet d'être
long